[Music]
hello there all right I just want to
take a moment to dip into our last week
tonight mailbag because as you may
recall last week on this exact program I
had a little bit of fun with some of the
health claims made by pom wonderful if
you know a man that you care about or
you are a man make him drink eight
ounces of pomegranate juice today
because what it does for prostate cancer
is amazing
oh really just give him a pomegranate
enema instead just shove a bottle of
pomegranate juice up his arse and
squeeze it you'll be amazed at the
results I may or may not have then
referred to their juice as snake oil and
encourage viewers to put stickers on
their bottles suggesting their juice
contains dogs
a few days after that segment aired and
this is true pom wonderful sent over a
tiny refrigerator and several cases of
their dog juice along with a letter they
sent a letter and I would like to read a
little bit if I may
dear mr. Oliver what fun
there's a full-stop they're not an
exclamation mark and that's a key
difference we did love the premiere of
your show we know that a huge amount of
heart and effort went into it for you
and your team passive-aggressive and it
was a great success hypothetical we know
it will continue to grow and evolve but
what a wonderful start you can taste the
sarcasm on the players a little we even
think that about the segment about pom
we take these things in the spirit of
good humor in which they're made
partially we like to think that we're
able to take a joke it was very funny
we laughed hard
and and you're spot-on with the problems
in food advertising and labeling you'll
forgive us for offering just a few
sentences of context here we go we
really have spent thirty five million
dollars to finance world-class research
on the health effect of pomegranates
that research isn't definitive but it
actually is promising we think consumers
know that they can't actually cheat
death by drinking juice and we think
we'll win our appeal that the FTC
totally overreacted to that kind of
hyperbole as for the idea of a pom enema
they say we'll take it under advisement
they then continued what you do with the
cooler full of pom is your business
so let me just say - pom wonderful a
kudos that is a beautifully crafted
letter because I seriously cannot think
of a more elegant way to say here's a
crate of our product go ahead and shove
it up your eyes
look if making fun of a product is the
way to get a shipment of it let me just
say this for the record right now
Rolex makes terrible watches just the
worst timepieces in the world please
please do keep your letters coming
[Applause]
[Music]